est ce que vous pouvez dire ce soir que
les états unis ont envahi l'irak enfants
dans leurs interventions sur des faux
envahi l'irak buzz en se tenant sur
leurs dix membres vertu duquel il y
avait des armes de destruction massive
et un danger immédiat sur la non or il
aurait dû savoir que les preuves étaient
trop faire plus tard on s'est aperçu
qu'il n'y avait pas d'armes de
destruction massive si ils avaient dit
qu'ils ont envahi l'irak pour se
débarrasser d'un affreux dictateur et
des régimes sans filière aurait été prêt
il n'aurait pas pu persuader le congrès
américain est clair n'aurait pas pu
persuader le parlement britannique
talleyrand guerre pour mettre fin à
cette dictature
peut-être qu'à l'avenir et dans l'avenir
des nations unies et des états unis nous
sommes prêts à mettre fin aux dictatures
simplement parce qu'elle est sanguinaire
est affreuse mais haas pour l'instant
non peut-être que le jour viendra et en
tout cas c'est le souhait que je forme
orale et alors